hi so my name is Sean vanaman and this
is a fire watch we're making this game
at campo santo and it's a first-person
exploration as you can see a game that
we're going to show you you've probably
seen some of this stuff before but this
is more of like that shipping quality of
the game
good morning Henry well I guess good
afternoon you probably slept like a rock
anyway there's still a few hours of
daylight to get some work in I can see
what your desk so call me when you're
ready
hey sorry guess I slept in you got a
relaxing what 14 hours of sleep wha yeah
Jesus I guess it's what 6 645 whoops
don't worry about it that hike puts
everyone out of commission for a day or
two but now that you're up let me
quickly get you acquainted with the job
there's a thing in the middle of your
room with a round map on it do you see
it okay yeah I see it this is the
Osbourne fire finder invented in 1914 by
WB Osborne you use this to spot you
guessed it fine what the [ __ ] what is it
nothing um you you use this to [ __ ] me
it got language lady out your west
facing window are you seeing what I'm
seeing how those [ __ ] fireworks I
need you to confirm do you see them whoa
that's not legal right uh no you need to
get down there right now and stop them
fire dangerous through the [ __ ] roof
is that really my job your job is
whatever I say it is the closest Ranger
is like two days away go down there and
set them straight
do I write him a ticket easy there Dirty
Harry well get going you'll probably
need a rope to get down the shale
between you and the lake if i remember
right there should be one in the supply
box on the way the code is 1234 it's
actually that for all of them secure
shut up sweet so yeah this is like we
have shown this before but I kind of
want to give people a little plants of
the fact that this game is coming out on
februari 9 therefore it's like in a
relatively complete state it'll
especially this early stuff so this is
like the area around your main power our
mission right now I believe is to go
find those ropes in a cash box and if i
zoom in on my map past 30 6 but you can
see that i'm walking away so i'll show
you around Henry's look at our area and
then we'll go get that rope and go deal
with whoever siding up these fireworks
so I'm also not well practiced at
navigating around this space so I'm
gonna have to refer to my map a couple
times less I go off the beaten path but
um well that's all points I should go up
to the impound so as you can see here
there's a whole sort of like new area of
the world that we put into the game this
area is known as ruby river and we can
cross over here to get you feel drugged
or services being for creating a
fraction el de las cuales you know how
the hell you ended up out here
look at my map really quick so I'm
clearly going the wrong way but people
manabe way I saw the job in the paper
and figured you know what the heck what
the heck I've got no ties and no life
better go spend what's left of it in
utter loneliness huh something like that
well thanks to last summer the bump in
Forest Service budget actually allowed
for us to advertise for the job glad it
worked so something that's come import
about this game as sort of the games
that we like to write is that like not
replying to Delilah is like totally fine
right now like I can keep the
conversation going and you know argue
miss let a timeout and it's no longer
pertinent so I may have missed the
moment there but that's the way life
goes it's like totally okay I
legitimately got myself lost by the way
Oh back of my power okay so check my
mouth again and we'll go to that cashbox
right now
walk down here yeah and like there's
trails in the game but kind of going off
the beaten path is I think the more fun
way to play
so i can now like add information to my
maps which is convenient looks like
someone has left a note for someone else
i am neither Ron nor day my name is
Henry so I could talk to the I'll about
that or take it or leave it but this is
what I'm here for I will probably take
this granola bar because why wouldn't we
take the granola bar you're coming with
us calabar we're going to go on a
journey and when you pick stuff up you
can obviously you can look at your hand
you can flip it around sweet pretty
great check out that nutritional info
just bring this with us
maybe I'll leave this over here
hopefully it'll be there tonight it will
probably be there tomorrow actually
almost certain it's of evidence of
wildlife here we could talk about but
we'll head on down to the lake talk to
these kids
so there's those fireworks going the
right way
yo this guy Oh somebody new area and I
can call out this this shale slide is
steep how do you expect me to get down
this I don't remember it being that bad
it's not even named on our topos see hmm
I think we'll go with the law at the
swearing of shitty boss is gonna get me
killed hill oh is that up sorta Indian
maybe maybe creek that's actually
English for not in my job description
down we go
oh hey what the hell's wrong with you my
shitty boss almost got me killed first
your boss is a delight secondly Jesus
what exactly happened my rope snapped
coming down the shale slide you didn't
break anything did you know i think i'll
make it will be careful for Christ's
sake
um there's a critter out here a raccoon
I can't understand you because I'm
whispering because you're whispering all
right litter down here how can I deal
with that didn't pay me to do with that
got a campfire I can stomp out I got
some fireworks I can take this is what
I've come for I can throw these into the
fire I could keep these I can just bring
them with me
I found a bra we're now we're the idiots
were shooting fireworks I think they're
naked meat
found them in the lake naked skinny
dipping yeah is that a guy over there
enjoy dealing with that I know you guys
are setting up bottle rockets out here
okay how because you're hiding in the
bushes spying on us give him a break
Lily he probably hasn't seen boobs in 20
years haha he probably still a virgin
what the are you throwing stuff at us
what was that your [ __ ] fireworks
what also setting off fireworks out here
isn't just stupid it's illegal yeah so
is stealing [ __ ] that's so [ __ ]
fo'get you're gonna say Venus take this
I think we can just call this successful
interaction fireworks we're out here
sad man and I go okay
so now we're gonna have music with us
for a while which is pretty great it was
fine oh yeah oh wow um music sound a
little loud oh sorry I took their stereo
okay well uh I can swear I'll even then
ya think so but seriously though thanks
for dealing with it
alright
so my mission now is probably to get
back to my lookout tower which is
somewhere this way and on the way I
could get just as lost as I got on the
way down to that Lake there's a whole
new section of the world up here that uh
you'll be able to see you in the game
chips now you can see it now but I've
been showing you this for a while and
yeah I just want to highlight just like
we tried to make a game that says like
expressive as possible and I mean
fashion to make like I said earlier we
just won't reply to Delilah right now
well yeah if you have an idea of
something you want to do in the game or
place you want to go we've really tried
to make sure that can happen
so there's an area over here we can go
in now goodbye
cuz I'm trying to get my way back to my
lookout tower I were to go this way look
at my map probably not the way I want to
go considering my lookout is here up
here and i am here i need to go south so
turn around and point myself south and
away we go
ah
hello what's in this cave down here in
Thunder Canyon Thunder Canyon hey I
didn't name it but in the cave I don't
know rocks tell people not to go too far
in there it's pretty dangerous so so I
say [ __ ] it you're a grown man you can
go where you want great used to go
caving with someone back in Colorado she
loved it might be great to explore it
sometime the summer well that could be
fun obviously be very careful
there's some guy out here giving me the
creeps the creeps wait he's looking at
you is he doing anything else I I don't
think so Henry there's there's something
I something someone should have told you
about this area what is it it's outside
come on the whole thing and people come
and go as they please it's it's it's
madness yeah yeah okay I get it [ __ ]
bumping into someone in the middle of
nowhere is part of the fun
oh damn it
uh what can I do for you well my
typewriter is on the ground outside of
my tower you right yeah look the wind
know how the hell you should get inside
[ __ ] me someone broke in a what it just
they wrecked the place through my
typewriter out the window mother [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] um I'll let the Forest Service
know what happened
my [ __ ] sheets are gone they stole
your sheets that's just mean yeah it
sucks the place is trashed can't believe
this [ __ ] then I have to fix the window
tomorrow Henry you won't be cold okay I
put in a call that was fast yeah well do
you have any idea who could have done
this I did probably piss off the girls
at the lake oh [ __ ] them well I'll have
the Rangers keep an eye out for a couple
of young women and question any they
find I can't believe someone would do
this I worry about bears and fires and
that's about it and now I've got to
worry about some deranged hiker going
after lookouts great not a great first
day for me no it's not I hope we didn't
drag a black cloud out here with you
okay in the morning I'm gonna call my
friend patty who works the desk down in
Cody they keep a list of everyone who's
officially been in and out of the
trailhead since I don't know forever and
see if we can get a list of names don't
get much but at least if anything else
happens we can refer to it and see if
anything comes up Thanks I need you to
feel safe out here just point me to the
forest service weapons cache they'll
feel safer than the Pope in his little
car yeah someone made the choice years
ago that leaving people with infinite
amounts of alone time and a gun
kind of a bad idea grenades I'll see
what I can do that's sort of the first
day of the game and right at this screen
right here you would actually see a day
to title card and you'd wake up the next
day delilah will have made the call or
to the front desk and you'll try to get
to the bottom of who could have messed
up your tower and then the mystery sort
of unfold from there the game comes out
on PSN and steam on the grey ninth and
thanks for watching